[Musique]
cette victoire de justine à sotchi a
pris racine en 2010 aux jeux de
vancouver
quand elle a vu sa soeur khloe terminé
5e de l'épreuve des bosses
c'est à ce moment là que justin a décidé
qu'elle allait mettre toute l'énergie
nécessaire pour jour être championne
olympique
beaucoup de gens ont entretenu le même
rêve sans succès pourquoi elle a réussi
qu aujourd hui 7 phone 7 ce fut en moi
qui adore l'adrénaline depuis toujours
depuis que ce jeune quand elle opte pour
les gars super forme
ok mon focus andré il sera mené vraiment
encore plus série d'accords plus concis
puis c'est vraiment là que j'te casse de
délivrer les meilleures performances
pour moi ç'a toujours été sur terre
le feu de la passion cette faculté à
offrir des performances sous pression
lui a permis d'être championne olympique
en 2014
champion du monde en 2015 ces succès
elle les doit probablement aussi
beaucoup aux frustrations qu'elle a vécu
en coupe du monde en 50 ans j'étais
deuxième derrière n'a connu mais pour ça
je dirais que c'est une constante
bataille avec ses pendants les autres
mais c'est envers toi même aux petits
battent pour être meilleur que la
version de toi et fière
il faut tu pousses faut que tu te
concentres encore plus loin que malgré
son tempérament de battante l'année 2017
a été plus complexe pour justin
troisième au classement de la saison de
la coupe du monde 3e au championnat du
monde
les performances bien sûr digne de
mention meilleur de sa de ses attentes
après tout ça je me dis je suis fier de
moi parce que j'ai pas lâcher à tous les
jours je me levais qui me battait
jusqu'à la fin en l'état j'ai
l'impression en moi que c'était ce qu'il
fallait qu'il m'arrive pour que je
rebondisse
on a toujours dit que j'étais encore
meilleur quand je rebondissais que
j'étais capable de le faire puis je le
crois puis je pense que ça me ressource
puis ça me permet de devoir encore plus
clairement défini mon objectif
marie josée turcotte inde au canada
montréal